when people are using the word gay in in
any social context I think that it's
really important to figure out the
intent of what they're saying a huge
part of people being in the closet for
so long was because nobody wanted to
utter those words and I think that
there's when it's it's used in an
inappropriate way there's a really
strong sense of pride and identity that
comes with that and I think that that's
really important if it's ever you know
ranking something or speaking of
something negatively or putting it you
know down a peg or down a notch that's
when there's just other words to use
there's better words to use that don't
carry that weight to people in the room
and and you might not even know who
those people are you might not even know
how that word affects somebody you could
be talking about their mom or their aunt
or their dad we hold each other
accountable to not use those words
because then it conveys the sentiment
that gay is less than empathy is such a
critical part of this in creating
empathetic communities specifically in
schools but in other places in in your
community in your place of worship and
your house we need to create these
empathetic environments and the way that
we create empathy is is by sharing our
stories and and the way that you have
that conversation about those words you
know gay being used in a negative way
people don't respond to no you shouldn't
say that they really respond to when you
say that it makes me feel that that that
and there's something incredibly
vulnerable about that especially around
the word gay sometimes that's kids
outing themselves when when they don't
necessarily want to which is such a huge
role for allies to be able to stand up
and say that words not okay because it
makes me feel that that that makeup not
because I'm gay but because I have
friends that are gay and and you're
speaking of them in a pejorative way or
you're putting them as a as a negative
connotation to something that they use
as a prideful descriptor you know there
comes a point if you are transgender and
you insist that your uncle you know
everybody's got like a crazy uncle
mine's uncle George he's crazy like you
never know what he's going to say but
you you you give him the benefit of
doubt and you
back that that he will be better at that
but if after you approach him and say
hey that you know gay jokes aren't funny
or I've asked you to use my preferred
pronoun and you're just not like I think
there's a part of intention to assume
that you know somebody without a
tremendous amount of background in it is
going to be able to you know by choice
which the pronoun that they've called
somebody for 25 years I don't think of
the fair expectation it took us a while
to figure out that we were gay and to
come to terms with that and handle that
and be able to say that out loud we have
to give people in our lives that we care
about that permission to do the same
thing but after a certain amount of time
if there's no remorse or that I mean I
think especially with people that were
close to we really you can tell when
someone's trying or if they're stumbling
or if they're not so so I think we give
them the benefit of the doubt as long as
it it feels right to us and that
relationship is still important but but
when we you we come to realization that
they actually are not trying and not
trying to be educated and and not having
those conversations then then then maybe
they maybe they can't change where maybe
there's a way to employ other family
members or allies or friends to go in
and have that conversation in a better
way but you know I don't there's there's
so many people in the world that that
are putting out positive energy and and
that you know you are gonna get so much
farther and if if you need to let
somebody go because of their inability
to try to change with you and be
respectful of you that's just kind of
the way it goes sometimes which is which
is hard I think obviously especially if
it's if it's family members but you know
no one has the right to stop you from
being you and from from respecting you
and you need to hold people to that
you